one
so good afternoon everybody thank you
for joining the live q a this is the
final live q a
of the conference and the theme was the
vaccine
development and therapeutics i have the
pleasure
of introducing the three speakers
of the four that presented in this
particular theme
we have dr krishna ella dr
singh and uh dr ernie sir cortex
with us uh who will answer your live
uh questions so uh
in order for us to happen i also like to
introduce my chrome moderator
for this event uh dr vibhujen
so before we begin um with the questions
i'd like to just mention that our
japanese
speaker unfortunately could not make it
to the event
uh today uh due to unforeseen
circumstances
so just a a note out there
uh i'll begin the questions uh first of
all
to dr singh uh there is a question for
you
uh with respect to uh elaboration on the
phase one and phase two human clinical
trials
that you mentioned in your presentation
in india
and how you plan to recruit patients for
those uh clinical
phase one and and phase two trials
okay this is sanjay so your question is
that how will recruit phase one and
phase two
so phase one is a simple
safety trial so we have to
go into those pockets where this disease
is not endemic
so this disease is endemic only in
certain part of the east part of india
and i am in the west part so maybe in
pune mumbai
delhi haryana we can do a small set of
recruitment close to 150 patients 150
volt
healthy volunteers and once we see that
our
different those schedules are giving
proper immune response and it is safe
then we will go ahead for the phase two
in these areas itself
so phase one and phase two is very easy
the phase three is the most challenging
one because
we have to go to endemic area to do this
but in the meantime also we are working
on the human challenge model and this is
a group in leiden
in netherlands we are working there and
if that comes out then our phase 2 and
phase 2 will be
much easier to do because now for most
of the diseases
we have human challenge model
fantastic and another question if i may
uh
with uh you mentioned about the fps
cereal bovine serum and the fact that
you need to clean that in the final
assay stage the final stage
what are some purification methods that
you're thinking about making sure that
you get depletion of
fds so
a standard guidance is available from
the regulatory agencies that
in the final preparation less than
x amount should be present the dose
which you are giving
and we have a column chromatography
and then few washing steps and that is
basically take care of that
so we are 10 times lower than that limit
so you have to qualify that essay that
your
final preparation is less than the
limits which has been given
by a standard test
great thank you over to dr anisa
thank you for your presentation on
flexible and smart manufacturing
there are a number of questions referred
to to your presentation
the first question is why do we need
multiple platforms to manufacture
vaccines
and what are some of the promises for
the second generation of platforms what
are some of the
um promising platforms for second
generation
yeah thank you for answering the
question so if you look at
the vacuum processes we we do have
what we call legacy processes or
traditional vaccine processes
like inactivated or live attenuated
viruses
and now we see in the last decade
there's been some
advancements and developments of new
platforms such as viral vectored vaccine
or virus-like particles
and most recently i think with coolid19
pandemic we witnessed the emergence of
nucleic acid-based vaccines so we are
dealing with multiple platforms and
most likely uh we still need to have
multiple
vaccine platforms because each of them
have
benefits in these advantages so for
example certain companies have decided
to go
even we are in emergency situation
within
traditional inactivated vaccine because
you basically are using the whole virus
and you give more chances to the immune
system
to uh deploy the multiple i would say
responses tactics so including cellular
responses
not just antibodies when you are
basically
using uh virus like particles or
virus vectors or even nucleic acids
you're designing it
i mean today that's how we do it we
designed it to target a particular
antigens
in that case uh in the case of code
we're targeting the spike protein
which we are basically are hoping that
immune the
immune system is is uh reacting to this
particular antigen
and deploying uh the proper response for
it
so but based on the clinical trials uh
results in and that's not just for kovis
we see that certain times
um there needs to have vaccines quickly
which will help
to reduce the burden of the disease and
uh for this reason we're probably doing
having a more targeted approach
but on the longer term we see sometimes
that
maybe other type of vaccine are needed
so we have a better and longer
longevity of the immune and the immune
response
so for this reason we cannot today stick
to only one platform when we might need
to have an arsenal of vaccines
we've seen also in the past that for
certain cases
uh like dengue there was a first
generation of vaccine which wasn't as
efficient as we were hoping and then
they would
need to develop another generation of
vaccine
so i would say the promises of the new
platform
to the second part of your question is
that they can help us accelerate our
response so nucleic acids
the base vaccines are definitely
promising but they might need to think
uh we might need to think about how we
could
design it even definitely differently in
the future
using more uh like structure what we
call reverse vaccinology more
bioinformatics
and develop maybe multiple antigen
vaccine targets multiple antigens
obviously
we are in always here in emergencies so
it's a little bit more
difficult to design uh vaccine smarter
so i think that's why the reason why we
all
we have to to keep these um as part of
the strategy for the future
great thank you anisa and you also refer
to decentralization of manufacturing
which is
a very interesting concept a very novel
concept
one of the questions that's coming is
how do you then
not compromise the standards across the
facilities
and methods and how do you ensure a sure
method transfer across the
different facilities when you
decentralize that
well so i mean there are already
companies that
are um having multiple sites across the
globe and and and for sure there are
challenges associated
um around tech transfers
uh for example uh if you take example of
flu vaccines you might have
different sites and
as much as companies are trying to keep
a harmonized uh
i would say and and standards um
around the process there will be um
there will lead to some need sometimes
to adapt and
take into considerations uh different
contexts and environment
in in another country um that being said
the way that i think i presented here
decentralized manufacturing
is that one first it could be completely
different sites
in in other words not necessarily run by
the same company
so it's the concept of having more more
sites than what we have today
uh where the majority of capacity is
concentrated in
in few countries and and mainly with uh
multinational companies
um and then that's one option that's the
one
one part of the concept the second
concept is one single company could have
that more more sites um that could think
about
like um pre-engineered uh platforms and
units
uh in order to keep that standard of
manufacturing
and then will be more like adapting to
local
environments for utilities or um
and safety requirements for example
which might vary from one country to
another so
that perhaps is a one challenge that
will have to be overcame
which means more collaborations also
with local regulatory authorities
obviously we'll have to uh to see
there are certain countries that have
more competent
local authorities than others so
there'll be caveats to that
to that but there is a hope that this
will evolve in the same time
fantastic and i think yes you're
absolutely right um it needs a
collaborative approach
across most likely continents and and
you mentioned the multinational
companies that could be involved with
um knowledge transfer and method
transfer
across that would be a major challenge
thank you anissa vivo over to you please
thanks for dr ella
there is one question for you from the
audience when it comes to covexing
uh we can see there are a lot of coping
19 strains
across the globe so is covaxian
uh will be effective against various
strains or is it specific to certain
strains
it's broad broad specific process i
can utilize other strains we have
evidences
that it is uh neutralizing other strain
cells
not a problem number one number two to
answer another angle
even if there's a change in the strain
if it doesn't work
if your manufacturing platforms are
exactly same
you can plug in the same another new
strain and may manufacture
and that is what is happening in the
flue action platform
in a flow fraction you know you don't do
every time the clinical trial
if your manufacturing platform is same
any change in the string
you plug in and you know make a product
so there are two ways
one answer is yes it is protecting the
other one
second is you can change anything
the flag or flexibility of the
manufacturing platform offers that
opportunity over
thank you thanks dr fella uh follow-up
question
uh as you might be aware of that in
southeast asia as well as
in some other countries in middle east
it is quite critical
for any to be um
hilarified so um is anything
biotech is doing in that direction so
that
patients from those countries can also
have an advantage
see what we are doing right now is the
uh the monkey
challenging sarah and human sarah
has gone to niv pulling
and they're also checking on
heterotyping homotypic
traits so we'll have more data probably
in another two weeks a lot of data will
be coming out
okay and uh another question
uh for dr ella is uh cytokine storms
uh it is saying that in
19 patients cytokine storms is one of
the key reason
for fertility um so how do you see like
uh first i would like to understand in
which
phase of clinical trials um we study
that
any of the um that
is there a cytokine storms or those kind
of situations there
so um are you guys testing that
uh in in human uh we are not tested in
the phase one and two
but uh what is being tested in monkeys
and hamsters
we vaccinated animals when we are given
a challenging at a very high dose of uh
live virus we have not seen much
and that's the one which is coming as a
publication
where absolutely lungs are clear
not nothing like a like a healthy
sorry uh just like healthy lungs so we
have pretty good data from the monkeys
and hamsters
and uh but in humans it might take some
more time
to prove us for us but not right now
okay
uh i will go to dr singh for one
question
doctor saying uh leishmania is a
parasite and
uh now you are working on parasite
since um how do you see a different form
viral
virus or bacterial diseases
is it more complex or what are the key
challenges in that area
dr thing can you hear me
i think we lose connection with dr singh
so i will go back to dr
ella with one no no i came back
okay good yes so please
can you repeat the question uh
so what's the difference between when
you work for vaccines for
parasites versus when you're working on
infectious disease from viruses or
bacteria
is it more challenging or how how the
entire plate form looks
different from other diseases
so this question can be divided into two
parts
one is just like if the virus
or the bacteria or parasite
goes inside a cell and it's reside there
then it becomes very difficult
to attack it so just like malaria
tuberculosis testing
work is going on for 50 60 100 years
and we don't have the vaccine at present
so this is very challenging but in case
of viruses which is available
freely it is much easier to develop that
platform so this is the way you can
define
bacteria parasite diseases while this is
depending upon how they are available in
the breast system and how they are
manipulating the immune response
thanks thanks dr swing um dr
ella you mentioned quite a
interesting thing that from where we
will get 3.5 billion
syringes and meters
when it come to the manufacturing of the
vaccine
how you are planning for getting that
much of raw material
for producing these many doses because i
believe it might be quite challenging to
get
all this from single manufacturer
across different platforms which you are
using
absolutely this is my personal question
i've been raising this for the last
three months
you know seven billion people two
dollars vaccine
15 to almost 14 to 15 million those of
syringes
needles i mean not even 20 manufacturers
can manufacture also so many syringes
and needles it's good i mean stainless
steel needles
go to manufacture it's going to be a
challenging task
so we need an alternative style that's
why i said
injectable is one of the strategy but we
need a nasal
delivery system uh like a blue mist
uh medium has done it
like that concept also has to build in
if you want to
reach the entire population uh coverage
of action
then we need a alternative delivery
strategy whether it's nasal
or oral whatever it is we need that
study
that's why i said unless we have
alternative strategy
we cannot have injectable strategies
although globally
okay and what about the raw materials
which you need
to manufacture these many doses do you
see any constraint on that side
we're going to see that we're already
seeing the problem of uh wilds
flip also bunks we're already seeing a
bunch problem
for a while so we are seeing that
material
thing and fortunately in india we have a
lot of manufacturers of glass wires
so we are safe not much importing
required
but certainly buns you know we import
from the west
so there is a demand and supply issues
coming in
and i think my feeling is
this is going to be continued the raw
material issues and even the you know
serum free media
if i wanted that is going to be shortage
too and
uh you know fatal cough syrup is going
to be shortage too and i think you know
even disposable technology is going to
be shorter i'm already see
chromatic of the matrix is a shortage
earlier you used to get it in 15 20 days
now it's taking three months four months
also i'm not sure about it
so i think we are facing problem already
and
fortunately what happened is we are a
multi-product company
we have other facilities matrixes are
available
so we're able to bridge some of the
places but certainly it's going to be
very challenging
and it is required for merck rge and
other companies also
to ramp up your production and whether
it is a
your membrane cartridges whatever it is
you know you need to also build
your bases it's not a multi-rom prompt
approach it is not only the actual
manufacturer
uh industry like merc and other people
also should increase their production
it's a challenging time for all of us
but certainly for us the syringe is
going to be challenging
and the government of india is now
thinking yes we never thought about the
problem before
now we are thinking how do we solve this
problem
india cannot manufacture more than 300
million syringes
and we're going to face a problem thank
you
dr
yeah thank you i have a question for you
when you look at epidemiological models
with seir
where you look at recovery recovered
patients
is there any strategy with a big country
like india 1.4 billion
that you would target the susceptible
and the infected population rather than
the recovered would that be maybe one
strategy that you may be able to
effectively distribute the vaccine one
it once it's developed across the
country
that i think is a wonderful question
it's extremely good question
but how do you identify a lot of
asymptomatic people
they have been infected but not showing
any center number one
category number two category who are
infected
but no immune response symptoms are
there
but no immune response third impacted
symptoms are there but the entire
the igg immune response drains out
within 2-3 months
so how do you identify all these
categories of people it's going to be
challenging
and uh our phase three everyday trial
strategy is going to be different uh so
we are looking at the
asymptomatic symptomatic all sort of
strategies we're looking at pastry
efficacy trial in that direction but
that is going to be challenging
uh i don't think we can concentrate on
few people
but i think uh it's going to be
challenging fast forward
sure thank you for that and a follow-up
question on that then in that case
uh how do you ensure herd immunity in
india do you have a
percentage window by which you think
that potentially hurt immunity can be
achieved following vaccination i mean
the the vaccine strategy is only to
create
hurt immunity that's only reason why
everybody's talking about
because uh many people who are infected
also the immune response is going down
and so there's going to be a problem
because they are not protected hundred
percent
number one absolutely people are talking
about the infection the infection
which i doubt the infections are real
yet uh but certainly what i can see
is uh the target population is going to
be challenging task for this
i don't know honestly everybody is now
confused right now globally
everybody's confused so let's bring the
first vaccine
let us see how do we create a herd
immediate immunity
unless you have 75 percent people are
vaccinated
you are not going to get hurt immunity
so 75
of people has to reach the vaccination
and that is going to be challenging for
the country also any country
particularly
high populated country like india with
1.3 billion
so that means you are not 900 million
people has to
get the wax so it's going to be
challenging and also
you have seen there are many of the
vaccine companies which are coming out
face through data
uh it may not be protecting the
transmission also properly
so there are tricky issues some of the
vaccine candidates
so i think we are going to see next
three months three four months
going to be challenging period to all of
us but
my feeling is my trust is that uh we
will find a solution
we will find a solution and i think we
will come out thank you fantastic
thank you dr ella for that answer i
think it's very looking very promising
and i'm
it's great to hear that an expert like
yourself is
looking looking at it in a very positive
way uh dr anisa i believe that you may
also want to comment on that last point
over to you please
yes forehand i just wanted to come on
comment on
on the basically point made that merck
and as well as other
real key raw materials in material
suppliers
uh needs to ramp up production in order
to basically
uh collectively meet the the need
uh to supply sufficient doses
and in general to fit how we can face
collectively outbreaks and pandemics
um so obviously it's always a challenge
to respond to unforecasted demand and
urgently ramp up production i think it's
the same problem with anyone
at the manufacturing industry space so
we have been working closely with
all most of the companies that are been
engaging with us
um to uh to
make that forecast available and engage
as soon as possible
uh to ramp up also production ourselves
in and supply um but i want to to
mention
something that i think it's a lesson
learned from past endemics and outbreaks
and even today
um is that if there is no a key
cooperation from the very beginning like
from day one
and that there is a very open
communication and transparency
uh securing particular key real
materials
even i think government presence as they
do de-risk a lot
manufacturers but they have to think
also about the raw materials that are
needed to manufacture either
diagnostics but also therapeutics and
vaccines
um so i think there is a need to have
better preparedness plans for the future
um
in order to make these type of i would
say
uh collaborations even more seamless
i think we've done tremendous efforts uh
within the industry uh since h1n1
there's been a lot of improvement but i
think there's still
more preparedness that can be done for a
longer term view than
in a short-term view because i think
right now we're focusing on short-term
production
by 2021 2022 but what's going to happen
next
how we can secure raw materials for the
future and how can we ensure so that
we're not jeopardizing uh other
life-saving drugs it's a lot of
questions uh i think here
but yeah collaboration and communication
is key
we're working our best also to do that
and follow the supply demand in this
emergency situation
thank you for that response now while
i've got you here uh doctor and you said
there's actually another question that
may be
relevant to this certainly around the
support of
merck in development of covet 19 vaccine
worldwide can you give us some more
detail on some of the collaborations
in particular and i think there is there
is one specific one in asia pacific
um would you like to elude on that
uh yeah sure so um
[Music]
i would say even before coding 19
pandemic one of our
uh key directions and pillar of the way
we
we basically uh support the vaccine
industry is collaboration
so and and one is really um
about advancing manufacturing templates
optimizing processes looking at uh
how we can increase titles and how we
can
increase recovery so that ultimately we
are meeting the cost
for those requirements and also trying
to think about simplification which i
think i eluded before in my presentation
um so that was always quite uh
um key for us and in general
we always are striving to support
our clients and partners
in their in their uh we say process
development endeavor with our
engineering and application
support um for kobe 19 uh what we've
been doing
we are basically i think supporting more
than 45
i think even close to 50 uh
manufacturers worldwide uh different
level of support
it could be uh obviously making sure
they're having the key raw materials and
systems that need they are needed
but we've been also uh been involved in
accelerating process development in
certain projects
i might have also heard about um
collaborations with the german institute
uh everything started earlier developing
a platform
for adenovirus vaccine and then base
vaccine
and then this was leveraged for kobe
which allowed to reduce the process
development time
dramatically um in asia pacific pacific
we there are a number of customers that
are uh working to develop cool with
maintenance vaccines and now we have a
good example here in the panel
um our objective is also to support and
and accelerate those uh development
in different ways um i would say we have
a public
there's been a public communication
about collaboration with vaccine in
australia
that and sometimes we you look at the
headlines
it's mainly the the major companies and
uh front runners that have have been
advertised by the media
but there's a lot of there's more than
that there's
more than 200 programs worldwide and a
number of companies in different
countries that are also looking to
develop
also second generation of courses 19
vaccine which are using uh
different strategies and could have
maybe
i would say better uptake in the future
so that's what we're doing with vaccine
in in australia
supporting their contract manufacturing
partner
with different materials and uh
consultancy so that they can also
accelerate their development time
yeah over thank you for that answer
great anissa thank you and it's good to
see that there's so many projects
um on the go in different stages
leave it over to you please
okay uh the next question i see is
coming for uh
dr sanders saying um
kim and he was talking about expediting
the overall vaccine development process
so uh from india perspective
what are the changes what changes are
required
in policy and regulatory ecosystem to
get
these vaccines out quickly
so that patients can get benefits
yes there was a standard traditional um
ways to handle it but now in indian
system also they have made some
quick ways to walk through it and
especially for kobe 19.
and but i'm i just get
little bit worried because i also come
from the regulatory side
in my past life
there are things can be expedited
regulatory agencies can help
to review the process faster than the
standard process
which is happening in government 19 but
it should also not be misused
that something which is not worthwhile
has crossed the lines
and you might be hearing this debate is
going on at usfd itself because the next
vaccine review is on 25th of october
because if something which is not
perfect has gone it will
be going to a big healthy population so
that worrisome point
need to be kept and need to be asked
asked
very rightly so regulatory pathways are
changing
and these are the time where government
of india in different departments has
taken the right
right moves but still i will say
this would be a causes way of doing it
because we are not
rushing against time we are the singing
is the virus
because at the end healthy population is
on the risk
thanks dr singh uh a related question
um there are other life diseases
and other mexican equally important
whether it is
rotavirus polio or theses
when everyone started working on kobe 19
obvious ensuring that those vaccine
production cycles
are going on track and there are no
constraints on those
very honest with you the situation which
has been created by
kobe 19 yes everything has affected
certain cases 5 10 certain cases much
more than that
and this effect will be seen very soon
and some analytics has come from the
bill melinda gates foundation recently
on it
but i feel this is individual
responsibility of manufacturer
government procurement systems
international and national agencies
that we cannot ignore those problems
in these days because once we control
the covet we should not
land in a situation where other diseases
have
made huge mortality so
certainly things are affected but the
agency then manufacture has to be very
cautious about it
to keep the balancing act
um what's your perspective dr ella on
the same question
that how in paris biotech you are
managing your other vaccines
manufacturing
and then bringing these three different
templates for kobe 19.
i didn't get a question um can you
repeat the question please
my question dr ella is that you are
already manufacturing other vaccines
or other uh critical diseases
and then there are more resources
required for covet 19. so how how you
are keeping a balance between two
so that people don't face a challenge of
shortening of
other other vaccines
yes this is a good question and every
every manufacturer is
facing the same problem right now
actually we have a double-edged problem
for us as a manufacturer
we need a gmp facility three different
platform
vaccine and three different
manufacturing facilities so it's a
challenging task
so fortunately we have diverted one
facility which is a brand new facility
we put it for the overweight
another coin we had a rabies faction we
shut down the rabies facts
and uh in the ravis platform basically
jefferson vaccine we are now making in
the
facility we shut down which is about uh
something like a 75 million dollar sales
product
we shut down the product we lose the
revenue 75 million dollars
gone one time and that you know we don't
know whether the action is going to work
or not
so what one thing what we did is we have
acquired a jsk vaccine plan
chiron berry in another city so we are
now increasing the capacity of rabies
fraction
there so we shut down here so a lot of
adjustments happening
and we are creating another new facility
in bone asia
that's getting ready so we are going to
be tremendous challenging task for us
one we are going to lose revenue of the
some of the existing vacuum
because we're diverting the facility for
the kovic and then
we're not taking any money from the
government or from any foundation
we thought it's our time to give back to
the society
because the countries are suffering with
the economy in collapse
so it's our time back payback to the
government
so we are working we are not taking any
money we are working ourselves
to pay back to the country like icm1
technology we are not taking any money
anywhere we are trying to pay back to
the country
so i think it's going to be challenging
we are affected by rabies faction for us
but not rota typhoid conjugate all of
them are very well
so the manpower is going to be shuffling
little bit and human risk is going to be
a little disturbed
so we are making them what 12 hours in a
day now
unfortunately so we're telling them as a
citizen
it's a time to pay back to the society
so we're making them to work 12 hours
so that eight hours once in one
production and four hours they work on a
forward watch
thank you
thank you dr ella it's quite inspiring
like how people
are working 12-hour shift and trying to
ensure that all the disease
all the vaccines which we are trying to
bring for people
are balanced uh over to you for heart
thank you vivo in closing the the live q
a
um i really like to thank uh all of our
speakers we've had uh
dr ella and dr singh from india uh
both very busy with obviously developing
their own vaccine work with with their
teams
so really want to thank you for for for
giving us the time
and the audience to to listen to your
progress
and also dr anissa joining us from mars
time in france
as part of merc life science r d
team thank you so much for your time and
i really want to again myself and we
will
thank you again for for joining our live
session
thank you thank you thank you very much
bye bye thank you very much thank you
thank you
thank you uh for heart with this we are
going to end our two days
uh great event and just to share with
you more than 1600 people join different
sessions in last two days
and it was a dream to bring scientific
community onto a single platform
from across asia and this was the first
time we were trying this plate
uh platform also um it worked really
well
uh despite of some small glitches
um but overall it was a great experience
for us
also to interact with scientists across
the globe across asia and to have great
audience coming from
all over asia from philippines vietnam
india korea china japan and
australia so uh how do you see this
like uh what are the next steps you see
from here
thank you people yes i think i would
definitely agree i think uh other than
that the great
uh audience we've had across asia
uh we've also had uh some very you know
high caliber speakers
within asia but also we had two speakers
from us
and of course one speaker from france
and europe so it's truly
become a global event
very quickly in terms of capturing those
speakers to try to really
um you know capture the topic in a good
way
i think going forward our plan
really is to keep continuing the
momentum of course
there is no vaccine out for covet 19 so
that always keeps the um the interest
alive
and uh one of our plans is to to really
keep
the momentum going with some certain
blogs
and and and scientific content that will
be available
uh across the um across the different
platforms within merck
that will be announced um soon
uh we will just back on you know to you
what are your thoughts in terms of how
we can
uh move the m m move the momentum
forward
uh with the conference and and the
content
yeah thanks from my perspective there
are three things
number one we got great speakers joining
us for this event
my request to all all the audiences that
this particular platform is going to be
available for
next one year if any one of you were not
able to join other sessions
please log in whenever you want to and
you can go through any of the content
you can download those in your cases
please do it please share it with
your other colleagues other infectious
disease researchers
so that they can also take advantage of
the great uh presentations from all
the speakers here second is we are
trying to build a community
on linkedin with all the infections to
these researchers
in apac where we will try to share uh
new development whenever there are new
technologies
uh or any new vaccines come coming
we will try to bring those speakers uh
in in a similar
way or maybe through our webinars so
please
join our linkedin community which will
uh we will bring
uh in the next week also uh
on on linkedin and the third thing is um
in mug there is one thing which we all
are proud of
our job is to accelerate scientific
research
we are always available any any of my
colleagues across
asia are committed to help our customers
to fight kobe 19.
anything you need any challenge you are
having
please don't try to contact our
technical team our sales people our
marketing folks
they are available to you to help you
in this difficult time um as
many of you will start going back to lab
please let us know whatever help merc
can provide
we are ready for it
well thank you vivo thank you vivi i
think uh the one last comment i also
like to make is
uh of course with dr kim dr ella
in particular i think dr ann wiley
their products are very well in advance
in terms
of commercialization
and distribution so one of the other
things we like to do is to keep the
engagement going
with them in particular with some uh
live
online interviews and so please watch
the space
for more events coming up with
uh with those particular uh academics as
well as some of the other academics in
terms of modeling
uh accuracy so we hope to uh
create this uh educational platform
by which we can as you said vivo
help researchers in not just reagents
and consumables and
and solutions for science but also
educational content
um as we learn more about this pandemic
and hopefully not not too many more
future pandemics but
um i think the more we learn about that
the
the more prepared we will be uh for any
potential
um new risks that are coming in into
society uh
so by that um i'd like to thank
everybody
uh vivu as you mentioned the audience
has been fantastic and engaged
throughout the last two days
and um i would say we would like to
end it at this stage by thanking
everybody again for joining
and please watch the space within our
platforms
thank you everyone thank you bye-bye
bye